[Music]
Nintendo announced at its January event
that it plans to have a subscription fee
for the switches online service but it
sounds like it won't cost quite as much
as what Sony and Microsoft offer I'm
Matt and this GameSpot news update is
free of charge
Nintendo president Tatsumi ki Mishima
told Japanese publication Nikkei that
the switches online service will cost
two thousand to three thousand yen a
year that converts to about 17 to $26
u.s. it's important to note that this
isn't a confirmation of North America's
price or any other regions however if it
is an indication of the services cost
it'll be significantly cheaper than Xbox
Live Gold and PlayStation Plus both of
which ask for $60 annually the switch
launches on March 3rd but the
subscription fee won't be required until
later this year not much is known about
the service other than its required for
online multiplayer and provides access
to a free classic game every month
however unlike the freebies from its
Sony and Microsoft counterparts you
don't get to keep the game after the
month is over we'll keep you updated on
all the Switch and Nintendo news so for
that and much more from the world of
video games stay tuned to game spots